Francia celebra la clasificación de su
selección a la final del mundial de
fútbol título que disputará Argentina
este domingo el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron recibió críticas por su
presencia en Qatar para las semifinal
Tenemos reporte de nuestra enviada
especial a doja
en Bruselas los líderes de la Unión
Europea se reúnen con el escándalo del
qatargate y la situación económica
derivada de la alta inflación y de la
crisis energética por la guerra en
Ucrania como trasfondo ampliamos desde
Bruselas
en Reino Unido las enfermeras están en
huelga para exigir mejores salarios y
condiciones laborales los sindicatos
estiman que más de 100.000 trabajadoras
del Sistema Nacional de salud británico
se sumaron a las protestas
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
deportiva porque hay alegría en Francia
que venció 2-0 a Marruecos en las
semifinal de Qatar 2022 Y que ahora se
prepara para enfrentar a Argentina en la
gran final de este domingo mientras la
afición francesa celebró la victoria
hasta altas horas de la noche el mundo
árabe se llenó de orgullo por la proeza
de los marroquis en esta copa mundo
previamente nuestra enviada especial a
Qatar Natalia Ruiz no reportaba Cuál es
el ambiente en la sede del mundial tras
la victoria del Blog
muy buenos días Pues todavía celebración
y de hecho ya hemos visto aquí por estas
calles en la zona donde nos encontramos
aquí en doja en hoteles ya están
poniendo banderas grandísimas tanto de
Francia como de Argentina muchísimas
celebración celebración también que tuvo
el presidente Manuel presente en ese
partido en la noche de ayer en el
estadio celebró con los jugadores de
Francia quienes abrazó también pudo
hablar con jugadores de Marruecos el
presidente lo han criticado mucho por
estar aquí pero él le dijo ya en Rusia
yo había hecho Exactamente lo mismo
había venido a apoyar al equipo La idea
es de compartir y de disfrutar este
momento dijo que esta copa del mundo no
tenía mayores problemas de organización
Qatar había ahí anotado pues muy buenos
puntos tampoco problemas de seguridad y
que todos esos temas otros que quedan
por resolver haciendo pues una Clara
alusión a los temas en cuanto a derecho
laboral en cuanto a derechos humanos
pues esas son cosas que pueden irse
hablando poco a poco y que finalmente el
fútbol puede ser ese tema ese eso
Federal a los países cuando no logran
finalmente hablarse políticamente En
todo caso él de esta manera pues ha
tratado de despejar todas las críticas
que se le han hecho de viajar en este
momento aquí sobre todo por parte de la
izquierda francesa
cambiamos de información vamos a
Bruselas donde los líderes de la Unión
Europea se reúnen este jueves con dos
grandes frentes abiertos por un lado la
situación económica derivada de la
inflación y de la crisis energética y
por otro lado la gestión del llamado
catergate el caso de corrupción que
vincula altos funcionarios europeos con
el cobro de sobornos por parte de Qatar
nuestra corresponsal en la capital
comunitaria Esther Herrera nos daba los
detalles de este escándalo
Buenos días las instituciones europeas
siguen en shoctas este supuesto caso de
corrupción hoy precisamente los
orientados desde estrasburgo han votado
una resolución con 541 votos a favor en
que han pedido más medidas y más
transparencia para evitar casos
parecidos y han pedido que se paralice
toda legislación que tenga que ver con
Qatar al respecto la presidenta de la
eurocámara Roberta mechola que está aquí
hoy en Bruselas ha anunciado un gran
paquete de medidas para reformar desde
dentro de la institución y la
institución Como por ejemplo proteger a
los informadores en caso de que desvelen
casos de corrupción y también se
prohibirá los grupos no oficiales de
amistad entre eurodiputados y países
para evitar por ejemplo sobornos además
también se prohibirá y se vigilará aún
más grupos de presión que intenten
influir en la legislación europea todo
esto se produce con más informaciones
que se están produciendo ayer Francesco
georghi la pareja de la ex
vicepresidenta Eva
declaración aceptó que participó en esta
supuesta trama de sobornos y además ha
apuntado a más eurodiputados al respecto
de todas maneras Eva Kylie no pudo
declarar debido a una huelga de
funcionarios en la prisión en la que se
encuentra por lo tanto tendrá que
declarar la semana que viene
en Reino Unido el personal de enfermería
del servicio nacional de salud empezó la
primera huelga de su historia las
enfermeras exigen mejores salarios y
condiciones laborales así como más
contrataciones según los sindicatos
100.000 trabajadoras participan en las
protestas este jueves en Inglaterra
Irlanda del Norte y gales leurel tiene
los detalles en el siguiente informe
[Aplausos]
Es la primera vez que las enfermeras
británicas salen a la calle desde la
fundación de su sindicato
nos hemos visto empujados a esta
situación ahora mismo estamos en huelga
y Habrá más huelgas tenemos que
reconocer que no estamos aquí por
elección y que no hemos hecho esto por
capricho fácil
piden una subida hasta la real de
alrededor del 19% para compensar años de
carencias argumentan que los bajos
salarios se traducen en escasez de
personal y en una atención precaria para
los pacientes el gobierno conservador se
ha mostrado implacable prometiendo
legislar para reducir el poder de los
sindicatos y negándose a reabrir las
negociaciones me traen en una habitación
me dicen que puedo hablar de cualquier
cosa menos de salarios cierran sus
libros no ponen ni un céntimo marrón más
sobre la mesa y se marchan y dan la
espalda a la profesión
un curso que tuvo también lugar el
miércoles en el parlamento entre el
líder una posición laborista quiero
estar mejor y el Primer Ministro
señor presidente que las enfermeras
estén en huelga es una vergüenza para
este gobierno en lugar de mostrar
liderazgo está jugando con la salud de
la gente
si él cree que es justo que se cumplan
las reivindicaciones salariales del 19%
que lo diga lo que es débil señor
presidente Es que él no es lo bastante
fuerte para enfrentarse a los sindicatos
el Reino Unido sumido a una crisis del
coste de la vida vive un momento de dar
atención desde los ferroviarios y el
servicio postal Hasta la policía de
fronteras se enfrenta a una oleada de
huelgas este invierno
América Latina es la región más
peligrosa del mundo para ejercer el
periodismo así lo evidencia el más
reciente informe de reporteros Sin
fronteras que indica que en 2022 uno de
cada dos asesinatos de periodistas
ocurrió en la región particularmente
México encabeza la lista de países más
peligrosos en Latinoamérica veamos el
informe de Daniela Blandón
un poco decoroso primer puesto para
América Latina el lugar de origen de más
de la mitad de los 57 periodistas
asesinados en lo corrido de 2022 según
reporteros Sin fronteras México Brasil y
Haití están a la cabeza en la región y
Ucrania Siria y yemen lo hacen en el
resto del mundo como lo Explica el jefe
Regional de la organización a France 24
vemos por ejemplo el caso de México que
es el cuarto año consecutivo en que es
el país del mundo más mortífero para los
trabajadores de medios También tenemos
el caso de Haití que ahí tenemos una
sorpresa no porque Haití en los años
anteriores no había casos de asesinatos
de periodistas o algunos casos puntuales
pero con todos los hechos de la crisis
política de seguridad pública que vive
el país los periodistas han sido blancos
sistemáticos los 53 periodistas en
prisión también reflejan una cifra nunca
vista y las mujeres que hace cuatro años
se representaban el 11% del total ahora
ostentan un 15% las mujeres están más
presentes en el en el periodismo o sea
están cada vez más en la primera línea
de coberturas de temas sensibles en
países que están muy marcados también
por una una un machismo estructural
además de los trabajadores de medios
asesinados 49 han desaparecido y otros
65 han sido secuestrados lo que para
reporteros Sin fronteras enmarca una
situación que calificó de extremadamente
inquietante continuamos con información
de nuestra región porque avanzan las
protestas en Perú sobre todo en las
regiones Rurales del Sur del país que
contribuyeron a hacer llegar al maestro
Pedro Castillo a la presidencia el año
pasado los manifestantes argumentan que
el expresidente detenido preventivamente
y acusado de rebelión fue víctima de las
élites de Lima y acusan a la nueva
presidenta Dina
de usurpar El Poder tras confirmar ocho
muertos en las protestas y declarar el
estado de emergencia a nivel nacional El
Ejecutivo peruano se plantea avanzar las
elecciones a 2023 en lugar de 2024 como
había anunciado inicialmente
llegamos así al final de esta edición
informativa pero sigan con nosotros y
con más información en France 24 y
24.com enseguida volvemos
[Música]